so before I get into talking about the
movie with you I like throwing a
curveball
um you've done a lot of stuff yeah
someone has actually never seen anything
you've done before yeah what is the
first thing you want them watching and
why and that okay that's such a mean
question because they're the I think it
would be one of three I think it's Walk
to Remember maybe
um which is probably not the answer you
expected
um that feels really the most internally
true for me that's my internal life
hairspray would be my external life
does that make any sense to you it does
and there's no wrong answer here it's
just uh you know there's going to be
people watching this uh who've never
seen anything you've done right remember
yeah that's true
um there and nor should they um but yeah
I mean watch remember is like this
little teeny tiny Sweet Love Story and
it's and it's uh
and it's simple and it's and it's it's
full of it's you know it's full of if
there's some curveballs in there but
it's
um because even if you get to like the
oh the thing with what what's her truth
and what's going on with her what he
then does is very unexpected and
um it's and pretty heroic for me like I
wish I hope to think that I'm that big a
person and that good a person and that
my love is that honest
now hairspray is very much all my
external stuff all of my you know I am
Tracy like I understand that with every
fiber of my being you know why would
anybody not want me to dance with why
would anybody not want anybody to dance
with whoever if we can all do this
together what is wrong with everybody
you know like for crying out loud just
do what's right you know
um because nothing else makes sense to
her
um so that that feels also very very
true for me as well
but anyway and then this movie is not to
be all Segway and stuff
um but this movie is very very true of
my
um current state which is the learning
to accept the way the world works and
wanting to
um and and
how am I happy what is it that I need to
do how am I supposed to like what do I
need to do
inside of the world in order to have the
most peace and joy in my life and that's
to accept that life isn't always great
and to really own that and go like it's
all of that stuff that makes the fabric
of Life rich and interesting frankly
I wouldn't want it any other way I
wouldn't want happily ever after as it's
prescribed in a fairy tale book like
that that because that means that life
suddenly goes into a flat line of just
like blissed out nothingness you know
yeah I mean there's what's funny is it's
something to that is that uh you might
get bored if everything was perfect
there's nothing to do
life stops right
um I so I'm friends with a bunch of
directors and they all have been telling
me about the chaos of the VFX industry
and how shots are so it's so difficult
to get things done yeah how did the VFX
sort of bottlenecks that are existing
affect your move uh quite a bit I mean I
there was a lot of stuff that I didn't
see until very very late in the game I'm
lucky that I worked with a team that
largely got it right because if stuff
had come in late that had not been good
and I'd had to send it back
I don't know that I would have it there
and you know I think more than anything
what it's talk what it's what's you know
people are dealing with
it's not the bottleneck is what the
bottleneck is the problem is it's the
release schedule you know everything
I think it it says a lot about how much
the effects
is woven into the industry now and how
dependent we are on VFX that now are
release schedules
and how many movies are held back
because of this you know what I mean it
was like there was some rough riding I
mean I'm lucky I I got everything pretty
much done I've spoken to a bunch of
people that have not and uh it's very
interesting so I have to ask you you're
a producer on Hocus Pocus too yes
massive hit for Disney plus just massive
right I know I know this is going to be
a huge hit for Disney plus but is there
a little bit in your heart like I wish
it was in movie theaters of course
because for me I mean I I you know I I
want the movie industry to survive and
they need movies so there's that balance
of you know what I mean oh my God I'm so
happy for your T-shirt right now I just
clocked it I got him I love I get so
happy anyway
um
so
um uh yes I uh when this movie switched
over from theatrical to
um like Hocus Pocus was always
designed for Disney plus like it was it
was actually I don't know if it would
exist if it weren't for Disney Plus
to be perfectly honest like the service
is the one that really convinced the
higher-ups to make it
um you know because streaming is just an
animal that cannot be sated you know
um it's just like it you must continue
to have all the content
um our movie flipped during early covid
um when they were really making all
these determinations would I love there
to be even a limited theatrical release
of this movie of course the movie is
very big the movie has scale
um it also has
sort of some operatic moments and big
emotion and all of that tied to it
and also
I want to see Amy's and Maya's and
everybody's performances 70 feet wide
you know because I'm a movie guy
um that said this is what it is and I'm
thrilled because
do am I gonna miss no opening weekend
and the terror of that I'm not gonna
miss that Terror like that like I'm good
I was just gonna ask you there is some
as a director there is some relief
knowing I don't have to be worried about
the Friday numbers yeah and I'm always
worried about Friday never so it's like
so
um you know especially like the kinds of
movies that I have historically made are
uncertain at the box office so
um
um
so it's nerve-wracking it's
nerve-wracking so I won't miss that but
the experience
I make a lot of Comedy
and the experience of a shared laugh in
a room is something I believe we could
all benefit from these days how much did
you guys debate on the story of what
this movie would be because I'm I'm
quite surprised it's taken this long to
make an enchanted sequel I've I've been
asking Amy and everyone else for years
when is this actually going to happen
but I am curious how you guys ultimately
decided on what the story was going to
be that you wanted to tell they had been
working on it forever
um I had a meeting at Disney
I talked to Sean about what the ideas
were around this movie and I said can I
walk away and think about it for a
second because I might have an idea here
I came back I pitched what is basically
the story
and I think he found that really really
intriguing and intriguing enough to put
it into development in this direction
and then I worked with Barry Richard
lagravones ultimately Bridget Hales
um Amy like and then Allen and Steven of
course
um to sort of make this go but the story
of Giselle
um not accepting the world as it is like
struggling with you know living in the
real world feeling distant from herself
and then ultimately realizing she's
consigned herself to being the
stepmother which is for Giselle a very
bad thing was always
the pitch that was always what it you
know how we how we got her there and
also I believe this story of turning the
whole world into a fairy tale that was
that was something that I'd pitched too
um
and I was like she's not a fish out of
water in the world anymore so you got to
make everybody else the fish out of
water
so
um but you know it was it's tough
because it's like and this is very
filmmakery talk but it's like you know I
didn't have
The Fish Out of Water story to work at
which is most of the comedy of the first
movie
is the Fish Out of Water hook and it's
also a romantic comedy was the first one
well unless I'm telling a divorce story
with her and Robert and then getting
like that nobody needs to see that so
now we're into a very so it's different
so how do you make the movie feel like
the first movie without having any of
the things that theoretically made the
first one a big hit you know I'll tell
you how Amy Adams and the rest of this
cast
and that's what you do you go with like
well where have these characters gone
and you put them in a place where they
are all patently dissatisfied
with their lives I got to stop with you
I'm just gonna say I know it's going to
be a huge hit so it's very kind of you
to say I'll just say I'll say congrats
early and um have a fantastic day thank
you for your time if you and collider
say it it must be true